Chris waters here folks with a somber GS
news update it appears that the days of
shooting fish in a barrel endlessly or
high of in a cave as the case may be in
an attempt to score legendary gear in
destiny have come to an end as bungees
latest patch has fixed the loot cave and
other exploits for good or guy
apparently spending hours shooting into
a cave wasn't the vision Bungie had for
destiny and in the dev notes on
bungie.net they say they will quote
decrease the efficiency of cave farming
and correspondingly increase Engram
drops from completing activities other
respawn areas have been increased in
different areas to avoid loot cave
replacements there are a few other
immediate changes taking effect you'll
still receive legendary gear from
completing Queens wrath missions but
you'll no longer be able to dismantle
that gear to produce ascendant materials
the patch today is focused on fixing
exploits but the dev notes go into depth
about changes we can expect in the
following months Bungie brings up the
guy everybody loves to hate the Crypt
arc apparently earlier in developments
the Crypt arc decoded n-grams of a given
color into gear of the same color when
they introduced randomness into it
Bungie quote didn't adequately
communicate the potential random
outcomes of decryption players expect
purple gear from purple engrams von z
says to expect changes to address this
soon there are also some hints of class
changes on the horizon as well as
several balance changes to weapons that
Bungie has in mind including increasing
the effective range of Scout rifles and
decreasing the range of auto rifles and
shotguns you can read the full patch
notes on bungie.net if you're curious
and if you want to know how all the
weapons stack up currently in destiny
stay tuned later today for the destiny
edition of the gun show right here on
gamespot
you